The BRAF inhibitors work
by essentially targeting the mutant protein. When BRAF
is mutated, there are abnormalities in its DNA,
it produces an abnormal protein. And this
abnormal BRAF protein essentially
drives signalling in the cell,
much more than it would in the normal cell. What the BRAF inhibitor does is
it binds to that protein and essentially stops it signalling,
and by stopping it signalling we essentially choke off the ability of the cancer cells to divide
and typically the cancer cell will then die.
So certainly what we see in patients in
the clinic treated with BRAF inhibitors
is almost quite miraculous which is
that
cancer lumps that we can see under the
patient's skin can almost disappear
within 4-5 weeks. Something we've never
seen before from any of the cancers we treat.
And when you look further by scans and
CT scans and what are called PET scans, and these are
hospital scans we do internally,
you see, similarly, evidence of the
cancer disappearing
or shrinking in a very dramatic fashion.
There is a twist in this tale which is that
so far what I've been telling you has been this almost miraculous benefit
from BRAF mutant melanoma patients
being treated with the right drug.
But unfortunately what we're finding is that within about a year to a year and a half
of starting treatment, and despite
remaining on this
BRAF inhibitor treatment, the cancer
comes back, and it comes back because it's
now resistant to the drug, it has developed resistance, and not
dissimilar to the resistance we see
with bacteria when we expose them to
antibiotics, if we use them for too long.
What's quite clear is that that
resistance is because they've acquired
brand new mutations in other genes
and that means we will have to think of
second-line treatments to
overcome this problem. So there's a lot
of research now
in actually biopsying these tumours
when they become resistant and doing
exactly what we did previously,
which is we can sequence a tumour and ask what's changed at the DNA
level, what are the new mutations that may be the cause for this resistance,
and we can take those cells and keep
them alive and now
screen them with many many drugs, we will now find they are resistant to the BRAF inhibitor
but are they now sensitive to
something different
and can we now offer that to the patient in the clinic.